Hello and welcome back. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. We are the second half of our
braid drain presentation. So braid drain. How do we remove the inflammation
that's driving us crazy? The inflammation that's inner braid that is causing
neuronal pathways to be blocked. That's causing all sorts of symptoms. So these
two presentations are not even close to covering everything that we need to cover.
So there'll be a lot of presentations on this. So stay tuned. Last week we
discussed the lymphatic system of the braid and you had that beautiful picture of
it. It's because it's not existed. And how these wonderful Dutch scientists
discovered that there's actually a glib phatic system to the braid when the
glial cells contract while we sleep. It caused this flooding of fluid to go
across our braid and just clean it all out. This tissue profusion across the
braid through the, from the cerebral spinal fluid that just washes all that
tissue exudate, all that waste products away. And so sleep is the number one
way you're going to clean your braid. That's really good. But I really sick and I
can't sleep all day. So understand we are we are making the assumption here that
you're getting rid of the cause. So that's a lot of other pieces to this puzzle
that we talk about in this whole entire program. But now we're trying to just
clean it out now that we've gotten rid of the cause or were the process of
killing the Lyme disease or killing taking out the heavy metal toxicity or
the process of healing the blood braid barrier. That's going to be a whole
multiple presentations in itself as well. But sleep is a major way that you do so
because you are decreasing the sympathetic nervous system tone. So remember there's
two sides of your of your autonomic nervous system. So remember we talked about
it's an anti-androgenic effect of sleep. So and we said that the sleep actually
causes a parasympathetic effect in your braid. So that's what we're going to talk
about now. How can we create this increased parasympathetic decreased sympathetic
tone in my braid? We really want that in our body. So when we test patients at our
office we test for that. There's a very specialized test that we can measure the
autonomic nervous system and see from a from a level of where you at from a
complete toe level. Are we hyper both of them or hypo both of them or are we
hyper sympathetic and or hyper parasympathetic. Really if I have any patient that
is suffering from any chronic disorder, I'd really like them to be a little bit
on the parasympathetic dominant side because it is the parasympathetic nervous
system that really is the healing nervous system that stimulates an immune
response that helps with detoxification, digestion, sexual function, rest, and
relaxation. So what it does to specific organs, the sympathetic increases the
heart rate. Well think about it. Sympathetic is the fight or flight. What do I need
if I get a runaway from a polar bear? I need my heart beat really strong. I need my
force of contraction really high. I need to constrict my blood vessel so I can
shut blood to the extremities really quick because I can run really fast away
from this polar bear. My lungs need to broke you dilate so that I could get oxygen
into my lungs as quick as possible and my body needs to be able to fight. So I need
everything that is not necessary for current survival to basically shut down.
And that is my parasympathetics. So my parasympathetics would slow my heart, would
decrease the force of contraction, would be in relaxation. I would have broke
your constriction because I don't need that that air going into my lungs so
quickly. I would have an increase got motility. So when I eat a big meal, I get
tired because my parasympathetics kick in to digest that food. When I when I'm
healing from a disorder, my parasympathetics are working to kick in my immune
system. So there's normally should be a balance between these two things. But when
I'm trying to heal, I really need to make sure that I'm not already stuck in a
sympathetic dominant state. And when I need to clear inflammation on my brain, I
do not want to be stuck in a sympathetic dominant state. So how are we going to
deal with decreased sympathetic dominance? Well, this wonderful stress
technique here is just to, that's a joke, don't beg your head of your computer
screen. But there's also it's a different stress techniques. How are we going to
decrease stress? How are we going to, you know, maybe change our job environment, work
on relationships that are causing stress? There's just too many to go over at
this time. You need to seek counseling if that is an issue in your life. If you
have constant stress from a dysfunctional relationship or dysfunctional job,
you need to seek help from that. And don't hesitate to seek professional help. We
need to understand our spiritual position. So we talk a lot about that in my
quiet place. I do a lot of preaching. So you get to listen to me, talk about where
who you really are in Christ as a believer. And really understanding that and
really that into our heart. Because most of us are raised in a perfect household.
We had parents that had issues. And we weren't that wasn't built into us. And so we
need someone different things to build that into us. That's what the whole
purpose of the quiet place is. We also need to fix our gut bio. And that is all
number of presentations on itself as well. Because if our gut is inflamed, it is
going to cause inflammation in the brain. And it's going to increase the sympathetic
tone of the brain. So gluten sensitivities, heavy metal toxicity in the gut, other
toxins in the gut, parasitic issues in the gut, all increase the sympathetic
tone of the gut and increase the sympathetic tone of the brain. So any leaky gut
disorders in such are going to increase the brain sympathetic nervous system.
Toted, you're not going to be able to flush, you're not going to get adequate
sleep. You're never going to get into that deep sleep that you need in order to flush
your brain. And during the day, you're going to be constantly be flooding
inflammation in your brain. Also looking at changing the brain's chemistry. So
there's neurotransmitters that communicate from one neuron to another. So the
neurons don't touch each other. They communicate through that little gap called a
sit-apps. And these neurotransmitters pass information to the other
neuron very quickly. Whether it's an imbalance in neurotransmitters, that there's
going to be an issue there. The immune response, remember I said there are certain
cells in the brain that control the immune response. Those are the microglial
cells. If there's an immune issue in the brain meeting an infection in the
brain like a mild Lyme disease that's ramped up constantly over time in the
brain, there's going to be the next light inflammation. So we want to control the
source. We got to get rid of that cause in order for any of this to work. Also
neurofeedback works wonderful to balance the brain and to decrease the
sympathetic tone. So in our office, that's what we always look at. If a person has a
hyper-sympathetic tone or both the sympathetic and the parasympathetic, is it a
hyper state? That would be in what's called a limbic state. Neurofeedback is the
treatment of choice for that. So that could help calm down the brain waves and help
healing to occur. So we want to look at how we're going to mimic sleep. So we
could mimic sleep with some specific nutrition. So the specific nutrition that
we would use on a patient to mimic sleep would be that same thing that we're
going to use on a high blood pressure patient to decrease that sympathetic
nervous system tone. So they are the classification of nutrients that are
called central alpha agonists. These central alpha agonists, there's drug
classification that are CAAs. We want to use natural ones that will help reduce
the sympathetic nervous system tone. We have a list of them there. Torried vitamin
K, B6 and C, zinc. I'm not going to read what you could read there. But those are
things that we would give a person, and there's different combination products
that are out there. I'll show you a couple in a second. There will help lower that
sympathetic nervous system tone. Because typically a person will have higher
than average blood pressure if they're at a sympathetic dominant state. There's
also natural ace inhibitors. Hawthorne is an herb that's a great natural ace
inhibitor. Promegranate is a great natural ace inhibitor. But in fact there was a
study done about a year and a half ago that they gave high blood pressure
patients. Simply eight ounces of pomegranate juice. Just the pomegranate pomegranate
juice a day. They drank eight ounces of pomegranate juice and it was
equivalent of taking 10 milligrams of the typically given ace inhibitor
medication unbelievable. Omega-3s, melatonin, picnogidol. These are all good
decreases of sympathetic tone. Now obviously with any of these you've got to make
sure if you're not TH water, TH2 dominant, you can't stimulate that system if you
are dominant in that system. Here's two products that we use that have these
things in there. HTA that stands for hypertension complex and paleobiol that we
use in our office that have those things. But there's a lot of products on the
market that have those same things. Your tank home for this is to make sure your
sleep, late in quality is the best that you can produce. You don't want to be
shortening your sleep to think that you're going to get more work done. You want to
make sure your quality of sleep is there and we have I have a whole other
presentation on how to improve that. Your emotional and spiritually that you're
grounded, that you take away issues that are emotional stressors that you make
sure you get counseling for those. Healing your gut, different neurotoxicity's
make sure that there isn't a toxin that's that you're currently being exposed to.
Otherwise you could do all this stuff and you always have this ramped up
inflammation. Neurofeedback is something that is so valuable to look into. We've
just seen miracles in our office with that and using some nutrients to mimic your
sleep. So that those are good pieces to the puzzle. Now we go adept with all of
these with future presentations. So stay to it. I hope this was helpful. Listen to it
again if you have to. Thanks. Have a great day.